[Musique]
sur les riffs de la yamuna le taj mahal
il y a quatre siècle l'empereur shah
jahan fit ériger ce palais à la mémoire
de son épouse l'empereur a voulu ce
mausolée tout en marbre blanc
il a fallu 20 ans et des milliers
d'hommes pour le construire
on dit qu'une fois leur travail accompli
bon nombre de ceux qui participèrent à
ce chantier hurlait main coupée
l'empereur shah jahan craignaient qu'ils
n'aillent reproduire ailleurs l'oeuvre
sacré ce marbre si blanc et si pur
provient des mines de makran à une
petite ville du rajasthan
[Musique]
jeune j'ai ramé mineurs amakrane à cent
mètres plus bas son travail l'attend
tous les matins avant d'affronter la
descente au bord du gouffre il implore
saturent
[Musique]
georges haram étaient paysans
il a quitté son village à 1000
kilomètres de là pour travailler à la
mine à chaque fois que je descends sur
cette échelle j'ai peur c'est dangereux
des pires peuvent tomber mais c'est la
volonté de dieu
beaucoup y ont déjà laissé leur peau il
arrive qu'un ouvrier soit écrasée par un
bloc de marbre qui s'est décrochée on a
beau se précipiter pour le secourir
l'homme est déjà mort de toute façon
c'est dieu seul qui décide de notre sort
[Applaudissements]
à la salle guidoni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ailleurs qu'à baba
le marbre très fragile ces extraits par
bloc 10 heures par jour jaune jerram
tape sur un burin
[Musique]
la paix
les plus gros blocs peuvent peser
plusieurs tonnes il faut parfois avoir
recours au marteau piqueur pour pouvoir
se servir plus tard du bureau
voilà
la poussière omniprésente entre dans la
gorge et pénètre les poumons dans les
mines de mac rana pour les ouvriers pas
de chaussures spéciales pas de masque
pas de casque de chantier
personne ici ne se préoccupe de la vie
des mineurs ont passé il n'y a pas
longtemps j'ai vu un homme mourir il
pire est tombé de la aux allures brisé
la jambe mineurs travaillaient au bord
d'un précipice la douleur lui a fait
perdre l'équilibré il est tombé dans le
vide
il s'est fracassé le crâne et il est
mort sur le coup
au coeur des monts harawa lit plus de
750 mine à ciel ouvert pour accéder aux
fonds des crevasses les hommes ne
disposent parfois que d'une corde
à
[Musique]
[Rires]
la pierre est hissé à la surface à
l'aide de treuils vétuste
en bas les mineurs risquent à chaque
chargement d'être touchés par des
pierres qui s'échappe des bennes on
compte 40 morts par an dans les mines de
la région
la quête du profit pousse les
propriétaires à creuser toujours plus
loin et toujours plus profond ce temple
au bord du vide a failli s'écrouler sous
les coups de pioche
[Musique]
monsieur singh se fait appeler le roi de
makram au coeur de la cité du marbre son
vieux palais et une terrasse qui domine
la ville voici ma crâne à mes ancêtres
régnait sur mac rana en 1608 avant tout
les mines nous appartenait aujourd'hui
elles sont divisées en centaine de
concessions les actes de propriété des
mines sépare chemin ils ont au moins
quatre siècles je les ai découverts dans
une vieille boîte en bois des moules au
fond cela m'intriguait et je les ai
gardées c'est écrit en arabe et en perse
l'empereur shah jian a fait dépêcher un
ingénieur il voulait du marbre pour
construire le taj mahal
alors mes ancêtres lui ont fourni le
marbre tous les jours des blocs par
deborah gras à dos d'éléphant et sur des
chars à boeufs les convois se succéder
les uns les autres pour répondre aux
désirs de l'empereur
on vient de loin pour acheter le marbre
de mac rana de l'uttar pradesh et du
pendjab et des 25 états de la fédération
1500 tonnes de pierres sont extraites
chaque jour est entreposé le long des
routes
cette industrie rapport plus de 200
millions de francs chaque année au
gouvernement indien
amakrane à georges arama le mal du pays
une fois par semaine il sera en ville
pour un marché très spécial ici on fait
commerce des dérivés du pavot 25 francs
le sac de 200 grammes
chaque mois jaune jara me consacre le
tiers de son salaire
georges haram rejoint ses compagnons de
travail pour leur cérémonial
hebdomadaire la poudre de pavot est un
fusée pour une décoction qu'il savoure
toujours ensemble
[Musique]
non
le ca nous brûle les entrailles l'opium
nous rend accro il pénètre dans chaque
veine de notre corps war l'opium permet
de rester fort si on n'en prend pas on
se sent faible
on tremble l'opium est une vieille
habitude chez nous même au vieillard en
prennent ici on est en exil s'est pour
en baver qu'on est là pendant des mois
on reste loin de nos proches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rappelle mes enfants au moment où
ont joué ensemble vous juriez avait que
moi je suis venu ici pour nourrir mes
parents au début j'aimais pas travailler
à la mine j'aimerais bien devenir
vendeur dans une boutique ou un débit de
thé de toute façon je veux faire autre
chose nos femmes ne sont pas là pour
faire la cuisine
cette corvée nous empoisonnent la vie
mais comment faire autrement
zhuzhou rame et ses compagnons vivent à
6 sur 12 mètres carrés
tous les matins c'est la prière au dieu
vishnou le dieu protecteur garant du
maintien de l'univers krishna qui
enseigne aux hommes
la délivrance ganesh celui qu'on invoque
avant d'entreprendre toute action
les ouvriers vivent là deux pas de la
mine ce local appartient au propriétaire
du site
il le met à disposition de ses employés
le soir seulement ils font ainsi office
de veilleur de nuit la journée la
chambre est transformée en entrepôt
lady
chaque matin john durham lance quelques
graines aux pigeons les anges gardiens
des mineurs
bon
c'est venir la mère aussi c'est la mère
du veau
pour nous les hindous c'est sacré il
faut lui faire des offrandes
chez nous c'est comme ça si on vénère
les animaux dieu sera clément avec nous
[Musique]
vous savez c'est l'appel du ventre qui
nous a fait venir ici
oui c'est vraiment la cause de la fin
qu'on est là moi je travaille dans les
carrières depuis vingt ans vingt ans que
je descends dans la mine parfois je
rentre au village mais sur une année
je passe trois mois chez moi et 9 mois
ici c'est long c'est très long si je
n'étais pas venu à ma cranna je n'aurais
pas pu survivre
c'est pour ça que je tiens le coup le
patron me donne tout juste de quoi
subsister et malgré tout j'arrive à
envoyer de l'argent ma famille
sansal ne pourrait pas manger on n'a pas
de toi ce n'est pas chez nous ici ma
femme n'est pas là ont sauvegardé son
donneur la femme doit rester dans sa
maison
s'ils ont la force à la quitter elle
aussi est déshonoré ma vie est dure mais
c'est comme ça qu'est ce que vous voulez
que j'y fasse
à 8 heures le contremaître fait démarrer
le compresseur
[Musique]
john durham change le câble du treuil
je descends aussi dans la mine mais je
préfère manier le treuil
en bas on peut se blesser ici c'est plus
facile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s'agit de hisser les blocs de marbre
pour les charger sur les camions tous
les hommes sont sollicités
bas valais
la manoeuvre s'effectue au millimètre la
moindre erreur et c'est la chute
voilà
[Musique]
amakrane 1 le marbre est partout
une fois par mois georges haram passe au
bureau de poste de la ville
je gagne 400 francs par mois l'autre
jour j'en envoyé 250 à ma femme par
l'intermédiaire d'un voisin qui retourne
au village
aujourd'hui je viens la poste pour
m'assurer que l'argent lui a bien été
remis
elle l'a fait lire par quelqu'un d'autre
comme ça elle peut comprendre moi même
si ça ne va pas je lui dis que tout va
bien pour la rassurer
sinon elle se fait du souci moi je garde
ses lettres dans cette petite boîte en
fait comme sa femme jeune femme est
analphabète il s'est fait lire les
lettres et on a appris le texte par
coeur
parfois il le répète ainsi de mémoire
un dernier bari prémar
i was my ce qu'est née d'un coup ce
serait ma femme est souvent inquiètes
c'est pour cela qu'elle m'écrit garder
le contact est important pour elle elle
est tellement triste tout seul elle se
demande quand je vais revenir si je lui
donne pas des nouvelles
comment pourrait-elle savoir ce qui se
passe ici mal au mollet la poussière de
marbre attaque les yeux une fois par
mois des médecins bénévoles viennent en
visite pour soigner entre autres
kératite et lésion de la cornée la
poussière de marbre tu es allé partout
ici rien ne se perd les femmes récupère
ce poison volatile pour la fabrication
des ciments les femmes mariées portent
le voile pour se protéger du regard des
hommes
[Applaudissements]
certaines travail social amine el
déblayent les carrières pour un accès
plus facile elle travaille tout autant
que les hommes pour deux fois moins 200
francs par mois au lieu de 400 francs
[Musique]
voiture avec chauffeur c'est l'équipage
de choix au mali le propriétaire de la
mine où travaillent joue djarrah choix
au mali a fait fortune grâce au marbre
à 78 ans il vient chaque jour à la mine
tous les matins vont venir
je prends mon bain rituel et je passe
autant
ensuite je viens à la mine
je me prosterne devant l'entrée et je
prie dieu je lui demande de protéger mes
ouvriers de faire en sorte que le
travail avance
je prie vishnou krishna et la déesse des
villes et mains jointes
j'implore la protection de tous ces
dieux
c'est jaune jarre ham qui a aujourd'hui
l'honneur et la responsabilité d'assurer
la descente du contremaître et de canal
le fils du patron
canayer venu pour décider quelle
nouvelle paroisse sera attaqué pour en
extraire le meilleur marbre
le fils cadet est là aussi en renfort il
s'occupe tout spécialement de la
dynamite
moi j'ai une licence
c'est une phase délicate car si ça
explose trop tôt on ne s'en sort pas
vivant
les fils du propriétaire sont déjà
remonté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant je vendais des friandises des
bonbons et puis j'ai acheté la mine tous
les jours
j'extrais des blocs ça fait chauffer la
marmite
la vie est chère on s'en sort
difficilement
lugano
ramzan le client est arrivé ils
vérifient lui même la qualité et le
volume du bloc qu'il a commandés
et à la clé
je construit des temples des temples et
encore des temples pour une grande firme
et c'est un bon business où il c'est un
bon business
monsieur singh le roi demag crânes à vis
très bien aussi grâce au marbre
[Musique]
à l'époque des rues étaient beaucoup
plus large aujourd'hui elles sont
devenus trop étroits
bonjour bonjour bonjour j'ai commencé en
1972 à bâtir des temples fabriquer des
sculptures des piliers des arches des
dom pour les monuments de la région
voilà notre entreprise c'est mon fils
qui la gère ici on fait de tout le fils
du roi surveille tout particulièrement
les tailleurs de pierre ils sont tous
musulmans est tailleur de pierre de père
en fils
[Musique]
c'est clair les yeux
oui
ceux qui tirent profit de la
construction des temples n'hésite pas à
employer des enfants ils sont recrutés
dès l'âge de 10 ans parfois plus jeunes
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps travail qu ici
un an
moi ça fait six ans tu aimes ton travail
combien tu gagnes tu n'as pas de salaire
mehdi lui combien je te donne je leur
donne 100 francs par mois
ils sont pas un sou et ici il ya de la
pierre et donc ils viennent y travailler
vont pas à l'école ils passent leur
temps à traîner dans la rue alors les
parents nous les envoie un métier on les
prend à 10 ans comme ça ils apprennent
quelque chose dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le marbre blanc de mac rana
est aussi utilisé pour la rénovation des
grands monuments de l'inde
les palais les mausolées sont
réhabilités selon la tradition je rame
travaillera toute sa vie pour extraire
le marbre qui sert à la renaissance des
monuments du pays
il ignore tout du taj mahal son seul
moment de répit
la pause déjeuner autour d'un verre de
thé au lait
vous connaissez le taj mahal le taj
mahal non je ne connais pas moi non plus
je n'ai jamais vu le taj mahal qu'est ce
qu'on en a à faire du taj mahal nous on
est ici pour manger le reste on s'en
fiche
[Musique]
et le taj mahal sublime impérial tout de
marbre blanc comme au premier jour
[Musique]